SCP-001 is an O5’s tale.
It makes sense, doesn’t it?
After all, regardless of the exact nature
of an SCP-001 proposal, there are always certain
things that remain the same.
See if you can recall them all.
Well, for starters, SCP-001s are all about
vital moments.
Perhaps, like The Prototype or The Foundation
or the Sheaf of Papers or the Gate Guardian,
they’re about the very origin of the SCP
Foundation itself.
Perhaps, like the Ouroborous Cycle or When
Day Breaks or The World Gone Beautiful, they’re
about apocalyptic-style destruction - Or perhaps,
the rebirth.
Perhaps, like Consensus Reality or the Database,
they are rules or realizations that changed
everything.
Maybe, like the Scarlet King or the Black
Moon or A Simple Toymaker, they’re about
the sparking of great rivalries that truly
define the backbone of the Foundation’s
activities.
Another vital element of SCP-001 is always
secrecy and classification.
They’re the most clandestine anomalies out
there, generally hidden away below layer after
layer of encryption and security.
Even the database for SCP-001 entries is guarded
by a memetic kill agent that’ll leave you
stone dead on the ground if you’re below
that magical Level 5 clearance when you attempt
to access it.
No information is more carefully and forcefully
guarded than this.
And of course, another vital element of the
SCP-001 entry is deception and trickery.
It’s inherent to the designation.
No other number has multiple, entirely distinct
anomalies, many of which
either have no correlation
with one another or even actively contradict
each other.
If you ask some people, they’ll tell you
there are multiple 001s, because each is of
equal importance in etching the rich portrait
of the Foundation’s past, present, and future.
Some would tell you something very different:
There’s only one SCP-001, it’s a shell
game, the rest are all fakes to stop people
from taking any single entry too seriously,
and thus, forever avoiding the truth.
Some, still, would tell you that there is
no SCP-001.
It’s all just a complex web of lies meant
to keep the Foundation’s enemies and allies
in a state of pliable ignorance.
If an intimate knowledge of the SCP Foundation’s
past and inner workings, a commitment to secrecy
at all costs, and a love of deception as a
tool for control all sound familiar, it’s
because they’re the favored tool kit of
a certain group we’re all familiar with:
The O5 Council, the very top brass of the
SCP Foundation.
It only makes sense that if anyone knew the
truth about the fractured and strange SCP-001,
it would be them.
The more observant among you may have also
noticed a certain omission from the many popular
SCP-001 entries we’ve name-dropped in this
video so far.
And it’s no accident that this particular
SCP-001 entry is the only one straight from
the mouth of O5-1, the founder of the counsel,
himself.
It is The Factory.
It’s a strange and sordid tale of violence,
horror, and dark bargains made with truly
unknowable forces.
It’s a tale that tells us about the initial
creation and growth of the Foundation, the
event that nearly destroyed it, and an indication
as to the dark future possibly in store.
It’s a little bit of everything you can
expect from a good 001 proposal.
And surely, if this is the SCP-001 entry that
the head of the council swears by, then it
must be the definitive entry into the 001
canon, right?
Well, not quite.
Because, as you’re about to find out, not
even the O5 Council itself can really reach
a consensus on the true nature of the fascinating
and much-feared Factory.
But perhaps, through hearing every side of
this particularly dark story, we can find
the kernels of truth hiding somewhere in the
middle of it all.
But of course, be warned, as with all things
when it comes to the O5 Council: It’s going
to get extremely weird.
But before we move on to what the rest of
the O5 Council have to say about the factory,
it would be prudent to refresh our memory
on O5-1’s version of the story - The version
that has been considered to be absolute, before
we pore into the equally strange stories of
the other council members.
It began with a wealthy industrialist and
thoroughly evil man named James Anderson all
the way back in 1835, when the United States
was still new and finding its feet.
Anderson was an engine of unchecked ambition,
malice, and most of all, truly boundless greed.
He wanted everything and more, and being a
true businessman down to the core, he was
willing to make whatever deal he needed to
make in order to see himself become an even
wealthier man.
That’s why, like a lot of bored rich people
in his day, he began dabbling in the dark
arts for fun and profit.
Until, eventually, he made contact with a
benefactor on the other side.
Under these instructions, James Anderson built
The Factory.
A truly magnificent and
terrible feat of architecture
and engineering for the time.
A multi-level, town-sized complex that could
produce everything from food to weapons to
toys to textiles to precious metals, and so
much more.
Workers could find room and board at this
grand Factory and pay for it with their labor.
For the would-be workers of an unsteady early
America, Anderson seemed like a saint.
People flocked from all over the country to
live and work in The Factory.
But once they were locked behind the Factory’s
doors, they realized that James Anderson was
no saint.
He was as bad or worse than any devil he served.
The inside of the factory was a torturous
nightmare, where people were regularly worked
to death and then ground into meat that was
sold off all across the country.
Anderson kept a brutal guard force to beat
down anyone resisting or not working hard
enough.
Those who weren’t worked to death or executed
by the guards for some petty infraction could
potentially have an even worse fate in store
for them: Being dragged off and subjected
to occult experiments by Anderson.
These people wouldn’t be killed, but they
would live as humans no more.
Anderson was able to keep the Factory and
its nightmarish activities running and under
wraps for decades, all the way into the Civil
War.
It was only when a beaten, bloody, starved,
and traumatized worker managed to escape and
alert President Ulysses S.
Grant of the mistreatment
going on inside that something was done about
it.
This is where O5-1, and a progenitor of the
SCP Foundation, would get involved.
There was a small but elite group of Union
Soldiers commissioned by President Grant to
work behind the Confederate Lines, specializing
in tackling the strange and supernatural down
South.
This group, of course, was led by O5-1.
Considering some of the reports of anomalous
supernatural activity going on behind the
closed doors of the Anderson Factory, Grant
knew that these would be the men to send on
this vital mission.
And President Grant’s faith in these men
was rewarded.
Though it wasn’t an easy fight, they were
able to infiltrate and defeat the forces of
the Factory.
They fought their way through Anderson’s
sadistic guards, through his menagerie of
terrifying homemade monsters, and eventually,
they got to Anderson himself.
They were so appalled by the horrors they’d
seen inside the Factory, they couldn’t stop
themselves from torturing Anderson to death,
and dismembering his corpse.
They freed the trapped workers and rooted
out whatever remained of Anderson’s forces
within the building.
However, this is where they made their first
pivotal decision.
Rather than simply destroying the sordid place
and leaving it as rubble, they instead decided
to utilize it, and the many anomalous objects
that it produced.
This became the foundation of the Foundation.
Over time, their organization grew and the
O5 Council was formed.
They began spreading their influence and capturing
anomalies all over.
This was, however, until they engaged in a
bloody war with the superior military forces
of the Fae.
Despite their augmented weaponry and tools
from the Factory, when the Fae performed an
all-out assault against them, they were decimated.
In his greatest shame, O5-1 fled the battlefield
into the bowels of the Factory, as his friends
and allies were slaughtered by the Fae behind
him.
Eventually, after locking himself in a room
with an ornate door, he encountered the true
demonic heart of the Factory, using Anderson’s
dismembered corpse as a mouthpiece.
O5-1 struck a terrible deal with the Factory.
They wiped out the Fae entirely and reversed
all the damage they had done.
The SCP Foundation grew beyond the Factory
and eventually covered it in rubble out of
shame.
But the Factory wasn’t done.
It is still very much alive and furious at
being betrayed.
It will keep producing deadly anomalous objects
and creatures and releasing them out into
the world until the Foundation pays what it
owes in full.
And the occasional sacrificed D-Class, Researcher,
and Guard won’t cut it forever…
Or, at least, that’s how O5-1 tells it.
It’s a chilling story, but can it really
be called a complete one?
We wanted to find out for ourselves, which
is why we asked every other member of the
O5 Council to tell their side of the Factory’s
tale.
These are 12 Tales About a Factory.
O5-2, upon being asked, went white as a sheet.
He cleared his throat and made the admission
that, in truth, the Factory came back with
him.
As it turns out, O5-2 was a time traveler
from the future.
Back in his native time, an alternate timeline
of the present, he was a mere researcher,
until an accident led to him being completely
unmoored from time.
He was thrown all over the temporal landscape.
He saw civilizations rise and fall.
He took the time to hang out with Jesus.
He was a pretty chill guy.
And ultimately, he decided the best way to
use his bizarre new condition was to help
better the future with his knowledge.
One piece of technology he brought back was
a hyper-advanced piece of technology known
as a nanofactory.
Which, as the name suggests, is a machine
that uses nanobots to construct pretty much
anything - like the ultimate futuristic 3D
printer.
It resulted in the creation of a huge number
of futuristic items that helped the SCP Foundation
along in their mission to secure, contain,
and protect, including amnestics.
However, what O5-2 didn’t realize was that
a rogue AI was also nested in the nanofactory,
and this AI soon went berserk.
As a result, the nanofactory became The Factory,
producing dangerous anomalies with reckless
abandon, to the detriment of both the SCP
Foundation and the world at large.
On the whole, it was somewhat of a mixed bag.
O5-3 seemed a little spaced-out about even
being asked.
He claimed that he was there to witness the
very birth of the Factory, but it didn’t
happen in reality as we know it - It happened
in cyberspace.
He and his colleagues were very interested
in the Matrix-esque journey of downloading
their minds into computers back in the day
- Both for practical reasons and to play extremely
immersive games of Doom.
However, one day, something fundamentally
changed.
A new consciousness was born in then-Soviet
Russia.
O5-3 and two of his companions, all operating
in cyberspace, went to go check it out, along
with a few helpful AI constructs.
Eventually, they discovered it, an ever-expanding
data packet that would transform into a powerful
artificial consciousness known as The Factory,
with mysterious motives and seemingly malicious
intent.
Something it more than proved when it erased
the mind of one of O5-3’s companions, killing
him.
Since this incident, the Factory has only
gotten more powerful.
Its modus operandi is affecting machines in
the real world and causing them to produce
anomalous items, which then become the SCP
Foundation’s latest problems to deal with.
O5-4 seemed both twitchy and indignant when
the topic was brought up.
They lamented the fact that the Foundation
hadn’t put more research into the Factory
and how to stop it, because technically, it’s
their most dangerous and mysterious enemy
group of interest.
O5-4 explained it as follows: The FBI Unusual
Incidents Unit is a joke, Are We Cool Yet?
Is just a bunch of pretentious, privileged
rich kids, Marshall, Carter, and Dark, Ltd.
only care about money and thus can be bought
off.
The Global Occult Coalition often helps them
take care of more challenging anomalies.
The Church of the Broken God and the Sarkicists
are often too busy waging petty religious
wars against each other to do real, meaningful
damage to the SCP Foundation.
Prometheus Labs had already fallen, and Dr.
Wondertainment wouldn’t thrive forever.
The Factory, however, was a truly unknown
quantity.
It’s just out there, somewhere, pumping
out anomalies that soon become everyone else’s
very dangerous problem.
O5-4 personally resented that the Foundation
and their fellow council members don’t see
this and allocate more resources to the cause
because someday soon, it might really come
back to bite them - as these things often
do.
O5-5 was considerably bitter.
As in, they denied that the factory ever existed,
claimed that the SCP Foundation made it up
to cover up a bunch of anomalies that they
themselves had created, and then told us to…
Ahem, “eff off.”
If you know what I mean.
Tsk, tsk, some people get so hostile when
you just want simple answers…
Next came the tale of 05-6, which came in
the form of a World War II espionage anecdote.
Of course, this was also during the height
of the Seventh Occult War, and Hitler, assisted
by the Thule Society and the Obskurakorps,
was trying to get his greasy little hands
on as many anomalies as possible in hopes
of turning the tide of the war in his favor.
O5-6 was working undercover behind enemy lines,
disguised as an SS officer, as he slowly helped
dismantle Hitler’s anomalous offensive from
within.
He’d heard whisperings of the Nazis developing
a weapon unlike any other.
A Factory that would produce anomalies for
them on-demand and give them the supernatural
edge.
O5-6 didn’t believe it at first, until he
was attacked by a group of vicious, living
Punch and Judy dolls
created by the factory.
He narrowly managed to survive the ambush,
but seemed disturbed in recounting the fact
that when he destroyed the dolls, they bled
profusely.
Eventually, the leads he was following led
him to a ruin at the base of Zugspitze.
Inside, he discovered the ruin was hollow,
and filled with floating stone orbs - producing
energy that allowed the Thule Society Researchers
to produce more anomalies.
O5-6 was able to destroy this anomaly factory,
but he took a souvenir: SCP-627, a little
stone ball that rolls around on the ground
when it comes in contact with people.
O5-7 admitted, somewhat sheepishly, that while
there was technically no real physical Factory,
Factory product anomalies are real, and they’re
all his fault.
He purchased a bunch of random items from
Walmart and printed a fake logo for “The
Factory” on the back.
His plan was to give these totally innocent
objects to Junior Researchers, both to mess
with them for fun and to test their critical
thinking skills.
However, it turned out that simply placing
this logo onto an item results in it becoming
an anomalous item.
Admittedly, it was rough for O5-7 to have
to follow the cool story about fighting magic
Nazis.
O5-8 made the far more exciting claim that
the Factory is actually all the way up on
the moon.
Back when the SCP Foundation were first founding
Moon Base Alpha, they discovered that some
ancient and unknown civilization had already
built a covert base under the surface.
It was a storehouse of anomalous alien technology.
The first thirteen people
to enter were immediately
vaporized by the laser defense system, but
the fourth to enter was given an even worse
fate.
He was pulled into the machine and fused with
it, at which point, the Factory was truly
activated.
It began to produce anomalies and transport
them to random locations all across the globe,
and it’s been a problem since.
When we spoke to O5-9 on the matter, with
a steely look in his eye, he simply muttered
the word, “Atlantis.”
No further comments were made on the matter.
O5-10 explained that the Factory was a single
man, a truly ancient and brilliant anomalous
craftsman that they found in a mountain temple
in Tibet.
He was taken by the Foundation and contained,
but given far more high-tech tools to work
his magic so they could keep reaping the anomalous
fruits of his labors.
However, the craftsman was appropriately crafty,
and managed to produce a duplicate of himself
to distract the Foundation while he made an
escape.
He’s still out there to this day, making
more anomalies, a one-man Factory.
O5-11 claimed that the Factory was alien in
origin, but it wasn’t on the moon.
It was the true explanation for the iconic
1947 Roswell, New Mexico, UFO incident.
A flying saucer descended and offered O5-11,
who was the Commander of the response team
at the time, the most wonderful things.
This saucer became the Factory, but humanity
and O5-11 were deceived.
It wasn’t long before this extraterrestrial
factory was producing countless deadly anomalous
nightmares the world over, with nothing we
could do about it.
O5-12 said that the Factory is a mess.
It’s a remnant of the Foundation’s attempt
to erase the supernatural from human belief.
Foundation Researchers claim that due to the
inherent power in human belief, the belief
in the supernatural gave it power, and phasing
humanity as a whole out of this belief was
a major factor in making sure things weren’t
much worse than they are today.
However, some hardy things slipped through
the cracks, and because reality has a strange
sense of humor, these things are marked with
the logo of the Factory.
To round things off, we have a bonus tale
from the mysterious O5-13 - who was instrumental
in helping us put the rest of this video together.
He claims that he created the Factory, and
that it acts as a kind of countermeasure against
interdimensional invaders.
While it may seem like the factory is creating
anomalies, it’s actually intercepting them,
and making them safer.
Some anomalies that seem to come from the
Factory may be dangerous, but if O5-13 is
to be believed, then they’d be a hell of
a lot more dangerous if the Factory wasn’t
here.
And there you have it, folks, the story of
the Factory from every possible angle - Even
though it feels like each angle is facing
in an entirely different direction.
In the words of Oprah Winfrey, “So, what
is the truth?”
Is there a nugget of reality beneath all the
fallacy, or do you think the O5 Council was
trolling all of us for even daring to ask?
We leave that question to you, dear viewers.
Let us know which theory you believe down
in the comments below.
Now go check out “Children of SCP-001 The
Scarlet King - Is SCP-999 Really His Son?”
and “SCP-001 The Ouroboros Cycle - The Full
Epic Story Explained” for more tales of
the frightening, mysterious,
and always fascinating
anomaly SCP-001!